You're a mean one
Mr Grinch
Northwest gives her mom Kim Kardashian a
grinch makeover just in time for the
holidays
Kim and Kanye West's eldest daughter put
her makeup skills to the test
transforming her famous Mama into the
famous Dr Seuss character on tick tock
[Music]
Northeast starts with concealer and
Foundation before applying green
eyeshadow face paint and lipstick and
she loves a little bit of makeup she
imposes it up rocking the final look and
we gotta say we're giving this look two
very green thumbs up nice kid check your
character she's really aware of makeup
yeah Kim looks like a blonder less furry
version of The Grinch and our hearts
just grew three sizes and what happened
then
well in Whoville they say that the
Grinch's small heart
grew three sizes that day of course it's
no secret that North loves to play with
makeup in fact back in 2018 Kim told ET
that her daughter was always getting
into her kkw beauty products I was
getting ready today and she was a little
too quiet and I look over and she's like
destroying the palette and has
just blue eyeshadow all over her entire
face oh the new kkw Beauty
black eyeliner
oh I actually had to put her on our PR
list and get her her own set of makeup
because she destroys all of mine when
she sees it and then I can't use it for
myself so she she definitely loves
makeup but her new favorite thing ever
is no one in the room no adults closing
the door with one of her friends or her
dolls and doing makeovers and no one can
see until the final look is done or
she'll freak out and cry and you know oh
North loves a before and after she loves
a before and after and over the years
North has given her mom lots and lots of
makeovers okay I think that's enough
Foundation
oh because on the other side we're gonna
do the cutie mark
um I think the foundation has to go
everywhere though I know
North gave Kim the minion treatment back
in April
[Music]
I don't know how you're gonna top that
and last year the mommy daughter Duo
shared this clip peeling away their epic
DIY special effects makeup
[Music]
northy even transformed herself into
Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer
you would even say it close
of course the two have shared tons of
quality content since launching their
joint Tick Tock account last year why
not but turns out they've actually been
making tick tocks in secret since 2020.
North has a private Tick Tock account so
we we do lots of tick tocks together and
she puts them in drafts she's not
allowed to post them but we have lots of
tick tocks I might post one soon and
since going public it's been nothing but
gem after gem You're a mean one
to quote North's Grandma Kris Jenner so
far she's doing amazing you're doing
amazing it pushes me out
[Music]